so sonia you can start it's fine okay
thank you
first of all let me thank the organizers
for inviting me today um
it's a real pleasure to give this
presentation
and i'm very sorry i can't be there in
person i would have loved to join the
discussions there um
okay so this
work that i present today is in part
based on joint work with alexander belta
so let me
get to the overview of what i want to do
so i'll tell you a bit about dynamic
modalities and my background is logic so
i come from model logic i'll tell you
everything about dynamic modalities i'll
look at the relational semantics
and at actions that change models
then i'll give you the general idea of a
dynamic semantics for conditionals
and then i look at a bunch of examples
of dynamic conditionals including
counterfactuals
um
and then later we get in point four to
an interpretation of quantum
conditionals
and i look at them as dynamic
conditionals but also as counterfactual
conditions so i will relate them
and then at the end we get to
conclusions and open questions
and i'm not going to deal today with
nintendo systems so there are many open
questions that are so
um there are still for the end
okay so dynamic modalities um
so one can naturally associate with any
action or an event alpha think about any
physical action or action that you could
do
a propositional operator which i'll
write as box alpha and i call this a
dynamic modality
so for every property or proposition phi
this direct modality as an operator
gives me a new proposition and that
proposition is denoted as box alpha phi
and the reading of it is just saying
that
after the action alpha phi holds now in
computer science this construct is known
as the weakest precondition
ensuring that fire satisfied after an
action alpha
as you saw on that slide i'm actually
looking at properties and propositions
in the same way this means that
i look at properties of any given system
so this can be you can think of a
multi-agent communication system in ai
or you can think of a quantum system
and i treat the properties of systems as
propositions in a logical language now
that idea of building a logical calculus
for physical properties that goes back
already to
1932 um in the moymon's work which you
see here in his book mathematical
foundations of quantum mechanics
because what he says there is that apart
from physical quantities such as
position momentum there exists another
category of concepts
that are important objects of physics
namely the properties of the states of
existence
and so
when i say property or proposition what
i mean is for instance the property that
a physical quantity takes a specific
value or that a particle is located in
the state space region with specific
coordinates
now what formula did was he argues that
the relation between the properties um
that there is a relation between these
properties and the projection operators
that are definable on the hilbert space
and that allows you to get some kind of
logical
calculus
we'll come back to that later on so
indeed i will see in the case of physics
quantum physics i will see these
properties as physical properties
related to projection operators or
equivalently to the close linear
subspaces of his respect
but first let me get back to my dynamic
modalities so i started the slides with
um box alpha my dynamic model operator
and
there are two ways or i'll give you two
ways to think about these dynamic
modalities and that's related to the
ways in which you think about the
actions also
so there is a local view of actions and
there is a global view or global
interpretation of actions so in the
local view
here we view alpha as a real action that
might actually happen
in the current state of the world so
this proposition
after alpha phi
here is a proposition about the possible
futures
of the real world if event alpha happens
in
the current world or in the current
state of my system
then after that phi will necessarily
come to be true
so that's one reading
of this model operator that i have
another reading would be to say that
well alpha
this action is a transformation or a
modification of the entire model that
represents
the possible worlds or the possible
states in which my system can be in
that would include even mental actions
that happen in the mind of a subject as
well as physical and metaphysical
actions so these are two different views
of how you can see an action happen
either as a local thing
in a given world or as a transformation
of an entire model
when i use the word model or state i use
them interchangeably so for me
the the notion of world comes from the
notion of possible roles as used in
philosophy all the logic and they
i can also see them as points in the
modular states of the system
now let's get to the relational
semantics
so these dynamic modalities
box alpha phi is i i've introduced them
they form the basis of propositional
dynamic logic
where the actions alpha are modeled as
binary relations
on
between the possible worlds or states of
my model m
so if two worlds s and t
are such that they are related from uh
by
i can go from s by action
alpha to t then this means that this
event alpha may happen in the world s
and it may change the world into
a new state t
so formally we have a semantics for this
modality now so this is my modality
const on my dynamic modality box of phi
and i use the logic notation the so this
first part just means that um
after alpha phi is true in a state s of
my model m
if and only if phi is true in a state t
for every states t that are related to s
by my action of
all right now
you can give a generalized semantics
using the idea of model transformers
which goes one step beyond the semantics
that i've just presented so
the global interpretation of actions
leads to this generalization because
intuitively the worlds of my model and
they represent real possibilities
so these can be future positive systemic
possibilities but an action does not
necess that action in a model does not
necessarily result
in any actualization of the real
possibilities that were already in the
model so it might mean that i have to
transfer the model or update the model
to a new one
so in the generalized semantics the
action alpha will be interpreted as
binary relations
uh between different models namely
between the worlds in the given model m
and the worlds in a different updated
model which i will write as n
with a superscript alpha
so this means that the semantics in that
so the generalized math is can be
written as follows so
after alpha phi is true in a state of my
model if phi is true in the updated
model and
superscript alpha
in the same state as
i write it like this but that might be
depending on
which modality we're looking at which
conditional we're looking at there might
be certain preconditions
that you need to require to make sure
that the action alpha can actually
happen in the middle end
now
so
um the modalities that i've written down
they are box modalities so i've written
them between the square brackets alpha
and they're
known to be universal modalities this
means they quantify
universally
over all the possible states
or worlds that may result by doing an
action in a given state
there is a dual to this and you can
define an existential modality
as the dual of the box modality by using
the negation and so then
using these type of brackets you write
down the existential modality
and you see indeed that this the
interpretation or the semantics for the
existential modality uses an existential
quantifier so
after alpha phi here using the
existential version it means that phi is
true in t for some t that is related to
s by alpha
all right now
there are many more things and actions
that you can consider so it would be
useful sometimes to use to consider also
the converse modality
so then we would take
the action that corresponds to this
would be the converse of the relation
for the relation of alpha
and we write it here using minus one in
a superscript as the modality which
would say
that alpha happened and phi was true
before alpha happens so before that in
computer science these constructs are
known as strongest post conditions
the interesting thing in propositional
dynamic logic if i take these things as
basic constructs of propositional
dynamic logic is that one can consider
natural regular operations on actions so
i can combine different actions in
different ways i can take the
non-deterministic choice of actions
first do alpha then do better i can do
the sequential composition of actions
first to one note so the first one was
do alpha or no beta and the second one
is the bunch of composition first to
alpha and then
or i can
iterate uh an action and the way to
write it is using the clinistar
so
here we repeat the action alpha some
finite number of times
and these constructs have um simple
relational definitions uh
so for this one you just take the union
of the relation so for the relation of
all from the relation of that
indeed so these actions uh allow us to
combine
so this this way you can combine these
actions in pdl propositional dynamic
logic
pdl comes also with one specific
construct which is very interesting for
us especially if i later move on to the
quantum case
so
propositional dynamic logic cons
contains a type of action alpha
which is seen as the abstract test of a
formula file so i write this action
alpha as question mark 5
and what it means the standard semantics
of it would say that this action can
happen on the world s
only if s satisfies fine so it's really
a test for fire in this case the action
doesn't do anything to the world so it
leaves the world as the state completely
unchanged
so this is a static action checks um it
tests whether or not phi is true
and the semantics for this action
now question mark fives for the testify
would here just be the p these pairs
were of states as where phi is true so
this consists of loops
where we know that phi is true
so it's a test action for checking
whether files
that's interesting because it allows us
to use together with the other
constructs that i have defined in
operations you can define complex
programs as propositional dynamic logic
terms so for instance
the standard do until operation
as a program is a specific action but
it's a complex one which is a
combination of specific terms from pdl
using this test
so you test for not phi
then you do alpha and you keep repeating
this until
you
you you reach your condition 5 so until
phi is actually true
all right so now let's get to the
dynamics so use this propositional
dynamic logic to give you a dynamic
semantics for a whole bunch of
conditionals so
the general idea is this you take some
type of conditionals 5 implies
sorry
and i'm going to associate with the
antecedent phi the conditionalization
action alpha phi
which is modeled as
a well-defined binary relation or a
model transformer r and then my
subscript here is alpha phi
and it has this natural intuitive
dynamic interpretation because what i
want is that
this implication if i implies size
through my state as of my model and if
my dynamic modality for the action
alpha that depends on the antecedent phi
holds so psi is true after alpha phi
that gives me a dynamic direct
interpretation of the conditional and of
course then
the important thing is is to specify in
detail
what this construct is so is it a model
transformer is it the binary relation
between the states of the models and
what conditions hold for this
and
there are many intuitive interpretations
uh for this action alpha phi
in my construct that i've written out so
it can be read as
maybe i'm testing whether phi is true
like question mark find a pdl test that
i had before or
maybe they should encode something like
learning that fi is true
or in belief revision theory i can think
about it as revising my beliefs with
fine
or i can do hypothetically accepting
that phi is the case
or when you get to and we will come to
this
the physics side here i would do a yes
no measurement of a property phi on a
physical system with a successful
outcome
or
and then we get to the counterfactual
interpretation i can perform
on the current representation of the
world a minimal change a mini surgery or
an intervention that realizes fine
so these different ways of reading it
will be
different correspond to different
conditionals but all seen
as dynamic conditionals in this
form of course they all will depend have
um
different conditions or extra
operators that may need to be added to
it so because in some cases the general
idea can straightforwardly be applied
in other cases quantum conditionals the
implica the application here will
involve some work but still it will fall
under this general program of seeing all
these conditionals as some form of
dynamic conditions
and
most of the conditionals
with the standard relational semantics
they cannot be seen as simple dynamic
modalities for some meaningful action so
the question is what is then the meaning
of alpha
what is the action specifically that
we're looking at
and indeed so many cases as well to see
the um
we might need to add dynamic modalities
to it the pd the regular pdl operations
or
uh epistemic or the hostic modalities to
capture them the desired meaning of
these conditions so
but i want to look at specific examples
so
the the first example here of this
dynamic conditional would be the
material implication so let's see how to
capture the material
well
the material implication and actually
this is known in the literature and
propositional dynamic logic
would actually be equivalent to this so
after a test for phi and now i'm using
as alpha the test the successful test
for phi that doesn't change the state
so after a successful test for phi then
psi holds so this is my dynamic modality
and you can prove that that is indeed
the case that if this is true then the
standard material implication from
classical logic holds
so that gives us a direct dynamic
rendering of the material implication as
a dynamic modality
for the static act so the action here is
a static action of
doing a test for a formula phi
right so that's very interesting um
another way
another place or
part of the literature where
these type of modalities are used the
dynamic modalities are used is to model
the act of learning and this also
relates to formal learning theory but
i'll not get into that part
so let's look at how to model this so
in the literature this is done in the
type of logics which are called dynamic
episomic logics
um
so they look at sentences of this form
it's bang fi psi
so bang fi here
explanation mark 5 is a specific action
alpha
and how do they read it they say after
fires learned psi holds
now this act of learning comes in this
case because it's a real knowledge
update so the agent really learns
something learns that why is the case so
this means this new information phi
is a hard fact and it comes with a
warranty of truthfulness
so
it is absolutely certain and truthful uh
new information that the agent learns in
this case
so dynamic epistemic logic in the
literature this is called the truthful
public announcement of phi
and in certain multi-agent contexts
um it is the action by which all agents
uh learn jointly publicly and
simultaneously that phi is the case
um
so on this in this setting if i restrict
to only a single agent who learns phi
then indeed this means learning with new
heart information that fights through
and after that psy holds
how do they model this
well in
the models in that case
um
they have to capture the the knowledge
of an agent so
suppose we model the agent's knowledge
about the real world as a set of
epistemic possibilities
so this consists of a set of possible
worlds that the agent considers possible
now the action bank phi which is my
action alpha here corresponds in that
case to the agent has a whole bunch of
epistemic possibilities somewhere fire
is true and some will find it's not true
now he learns phi and what it does to
the model is that it eliminates all the
not five worlds from am
from my original model
so this action is an example of a model
transformer it transforms the model that
has possible not firewalls into a model
where there's no firewalls are deleted
for probable
probabilistic models
um
in which the possible worlds are
assigned subjective probabilities this
action directly corresponds to bayesian
conditionalization
because in that case uh after
eliminating the not firewalls you have
to re-normalize
the probabilities over the remaining set
of words
and in model theory this action of bank
phi
corresponds to what is known a model
theory as relativization of a model to a
sentence phi so the model is transformed
by eliminating some of the note five
worlds and restricting
all the re the relations that you might
have over these possible worlds to the
remaining words
okay so that's in a nutshell how they
model um
learning acts of agents in multi-agent
systems for their using dynamic
epistemic logic now another example
i go briefly over these examples without
giving you a lot of details in it so i
will get
to a bit more details when we get to
quantum but we can come back if there
are questions about this because i know
this was very fast
so in case we are modeling not knowledge
updates but the belief changes of agents
so in this case they also consider the
dynamic mobility which is here written
on the bottom of the slide
so after action of
psi holds where action alpha now is up
arrow file and up arrify means we do a
lexicographic upgrade with the sentence
five
what does this lexicographic upgrade as
an action do
well it in you introduces to the agent
phi as soft information which is not
necessarily true so this is not
necessary there's no warranty of
truthfulness here so the agent only
comes to believe that phi is the case
without necessarily knowing it for sure
so he might still regard not phi as a
possibility but he should believe five
so
these type of models have a plausibility
ordering over them
and what the action
of rfi does is it changes this
plausibility order in such a way that
the firewalls will become more plausible
than the not five ones
right so that's one way in which uh
belief revision theory
uh
has to use this idea and then dynamic
epistemic logic you can make that belief
revision
operator
explicit using the dynamic conditionals
now let's get to another example of
dynamic conditionals and this would be
the counterfactuals
so take the cement so i'm taking the
semantics of counterfactuals in terms of
rob stahlmarker selection functions as
generalized by david lutz so i'll first
look at their sets
and what they say here is that for each
proposition phi and each possible world
s we are uh we are given a set of
possible words satisfying phi and this
is written as
the selection function depending on phi
and s so the worlds in that set so the
world's t in this set they can be
thought of as the most similar worlds to
s that satisfy fine
so the lewis of course the selection
function will have to satisfy a number
of conditions can't go
into all this but the
the lewis counter factual
um
if it had been the case that phi then it
would have been the case that psi and
this typically is written in this way
is defined to hold if psi holes in the
most similar worlds that satisfy phi
so using my
semantic notation
the the notation for the semantics and
you see this counterfactual is true in a
state as in my model if psi is true in
all states c
that are related by the selection
function to s in this way
so that's the standard way which um
talneker and lewis have introduced this
notion of
counterfactuals and their semantics
now the lewis semantics can be
dynamically repackaged in a trivial way
by associating to each selection
function f and a world as
the conditionalization action alpha that
should depend on the antecedent phi
so i can define this relation as to t
depending for alpha phi
when the selection function holds
so
in that way you obviously have that you
can re-write
the semantics for the counterfeit tools
as a dynamic conditional as the same
dynamic conditional format that we saw
before
the only problem here is how can you now
in given interpretation in a natural
operational way of what this action
should be
what is this action all for the depends
on the antecedent when i give this
interpretation
of counterfactuals
now you cannot interpret it in general
as a realistic action that can actually
happen in the real world because that's
not in line with what counterfactuals
stand for
so typically these actions are real
counterfeit so performing it would
correspond to what lewis has called a
small miracle seen as a real action a
violation of the laws of nature
but if i take my second reading of what
an action is so the global reading that
i introduced from the beginning then now
i can reinterpret alpha phi
as an action that can
happen to the model so as a model
transformer and not necessarily as an
action in a mode so natural way to do
this is to minimally transform
having
any given world by a series of small
interventions in order to
to meet the requirement fine
in order to to get to the closest
possible world performance
so these model transformers they can
comprise all kinds of actions so that
can be actions from the past the present
the futures it can even be lewis's
abstract small miracles
so at a conceptual level this global
interpretation of actions where i look
at them as mobile transformers that
bears a direct similarity in the case of
counterfactuals with a structural
account of controversial step further
has uh that refers to paul's work where
he uses the terms of many circumventions
as representing small changes into a
causal movement
now another example that is of course
related to this are the causal
intervention conditionals so first we
looked at counterfactual sala lewis and
stallmaker and now i look at
the causal intervention conditionals so
i refer here to the work of joe halperin
and that's his book on actual causality
as well as other logicians who have
formalized the interventionist accounts
to causality
so
they have a logical setting where they
have formulas of this form
and actually it is written already using
the dynamic modality notation that i
have from the beginning this notation is
used in halperin's book
although they don't refer
directly to it as a dynamic modality but
that's actually what's going on so the
reading of this is
after intervening uh we're setting the
variables in the set y
to the values uh
in small y and then this formula psi
should hold
and what is the semantics of it
the semantics says that given a model m
and a given context where we determine
the exogenous variables
then the updated model which will be
written as this with a subscript the
updated model would then be the
transform model that results from doing
an intervention and
resetting the values so that in the way
that they should be
so then this conditional holds if and
only if psi holds in the updated model
of course in this way so you see that
this fits with my general
semantics as the dynamic condition so
the interventions here come from outside
the system so we know that they disrupt
the system and of course there's much
more to say about it
halperin together with plural they
provide
specific conditions that need to hold
when we're talking about actual
causality
and there are conditions that need to be
insured in order to to make sure that
the interventions perform a minimal
action for a minimum
system
now let's get to quantum conditionals um
just to just to tell you there is more
or less ten minutes left i guess it's
fine but yeah that's fine thank you
okay so this is uh more or less lost
part of the presentation indeed so i get
to the quantum part
so here i look at uh quantum logic
and as usually represented it's a
non-classical logic with the same syntax
a standard propositional logic but with
different laws and specifically
disruptivity is one of the laws that
needs to be weakened or that fails and
this logic goes back to birkhov neumann
in 1936 and to the work of
32. there's a lot of work after that on
these type of logics now
i'll give you my notation for
i will use a notation for a quantum
negation and for that i use sim phi
and i call it also the autocomplement
i have a notation for this junction
quantum disjunction for which i have
this square this junction
and i have a notation for a quantum
implication which is written with the
superscript as um
tell you what that means so
the disjunction actually is definable
using the demorgan loss which holds in
logic using the negation and conjunction
so that's not very special
um
now the quantum conditional
and so this s as a superscript and the
conditional comes from the s from sasaki
hook
the sasaki hook as a conditional is
definable using the quantum negation the
quantum disjunction and the conjunction
and this implication here so the sucky
hook satisfies
modus ponens and it behaves in a certain
way but it does not satisfy the
deduction tier
and it has been a long-standing problem
to give a realistic operational
expectation
now
before i get to further discussion let
me tell you what my semantics is for
these sentences in quantum logic that
i'm using
so i assume a state of a physical system
to be represented by a non-zero vector
in the hilbert space
and the false the possible physical
properties of the system correspond to
close linear subspaces of that hilbert
space
say that the state satisfies a property
if it belongs to that subspace
the sentences in quantum logic are
interpreted as linear subspaces
the order complement is
so the sim phi is the orthogonal
subspace 2 phi
the conjunction will be interpreted as
the intersection of subspaces
and this junction would be represented
as the the subspace generated by the
union of the
all right now why does this deduction
theorem fail for this quantum
implication because
here i have a statement of the deduction
term
uh because we know from logic that any
binary connective
so any implication here that satisfies
this theorem and this is actually the
implicative rule together with exponents
it's necessarily distributed so this
introduces this activity and that is a
problem quantum logic so that means this
deduction theorem cannot hold
now where are we left with because in
implication you typically want to
satisfy this law of entailment so phi
should imply psi
if psi follows from phi
and now if we want this to hold then the
question is what type of implication in
the quantum case can we get well there
are actually five possible definitions
of binary
implications state defined in terms of
quantum conjunctions and disjunctions
that satisfy this flaw now the sosaki
hook is the one that i introduced and
it's the best behaved one
because it is locally boolean so if i
take a sub logic
um
a classical sublogic then i see that
that sucky hook will behave as a
material implication on the classical
parts
so it's actually a nice behaved
uh the nicest behaved quantum
implication that we can define
now
um
what is this how should we read or
interpret this so the quantum
conditional has been seen as a style
marker counterfactual by hard degree
gary harnegre actually saw that it
satisfies all the properties of the
stallnocker counterfactual
and of course the possible worlds here
are the states of the system so the
vectors in my hilberts
but then the question is well it's fine
we can interpret the sasaki hook in this
way namely saying that psi is true in
the most similar state of the world to
the real one that satisfies phi
but what does quantum logic have to do
with counterfactual reasoning
well actually what are the selection
functions so i introduced the selection
functions from the factuals so here the
selection functions are the role of
selection functions displayed by the
projectors on the hilbert space
so for each subspace on the elbow space
there is a unique projector onto the
subspace which maps every vector v to
the vector of the application for that
projector onto v and so you can
write the semantics now in this way i
can say that the quantum implication
holds in this state if psi holds
onto after applying this projector here
on the side
on file
this shows indeed that the projector is
a style knocker
selection function for quantum
conditionals when they're seen as
tallneck and lure conditions
but then the question should come like
but we are not interpreting the
projectors of quantum theory in terms of
contractuals they are not similarity
relations or small miracles they are
used to represent measurements moreover
they're part of yes no measurements so
yes no measurement for a binary
measurement of a property 5 corresponds
to a pair of projectors one onto the
subspecify and one onto the subspace not
5.
now
if i link those type of measurements to
quantum theory then there's a lot to say
about it because my view they're related
to ideal measurements of the first kind
as they were introduced by wolfgang
pauli
we will come we could come back to that
later so
what i did in my work was that reviewed
these projectors now as quantum tests
for five so i use the pdl notion of a
test for phi but now the quantum version
of it
and it would correspond to the action of
performing a measurement that
successfully tests the property phi
so i denote it as question mark 5 but
now with a subscript q for quantum test
so far
what it allows me to do is actually to
say that this projector structure the
hilbert space as a dynamic crypto model
as a label transition system
with the non-zero vectors as possible
worlds and these quantum tests as
actions given by project
so
this means that the sasaki who can be
rewritten as a dynamic conditional for a
quantum test so for projective
measurements where i do successful tests
so the yes part of a yes no measurement
and after that sorry that the
consequence should be should hold so in
other words this sasaki hook implication
says that if property phi is established
by successful quantum measurement then
property psi holds after that
now i am viewing these quantum tests as
interventions
they are deterministic because
measurements are not their measurements
themselves yes no measurements are
indeterministic but
the quantum tests the yes part of this
is a deterministic option
um
and you always have this indeed that
after
performing this action after doing a
quantum test for five five volts
so these are actions of the type alpha
phi that we've seen
of course they are not the miracles of
lures but these are real possible in the
physical world so i view them as these
quantum tests as interventions all occur
they do disrupt the internal ongoing
causal dynamics of the quantum system
and the internal causal dynamics i would
capture that using unitary revolutions
and the interventions using this one
test
of course the quantum tests also come
with uh can be seen as a learning action
because an observer learns information
after doing that
that test but what they learn is
something about what is true after
performing the test and not about what
was through before performing the best
now here is a table we can come back to
this if there are questions where i just
compare all these uh different operators
that we've seen so this is my dynamic
conditional
and alpha phi can be interpreted as a
test the pdl test for phi as a public
announcement for phi as the belief
revision would fly as a quantum test
or as
a lewis type of counterfactual action
and then you can really compare what is
going on at what every different level
with these different uh conditionals now
let me get to the conclusion i hope
there's maybe still some time for a
question
uh so i use logic to compare ontake and
epistemic informational aspects of
various conditionals
and i am really aiming for a unified
setting where it can capture both
classical and quantum conditions
um
the local and global view of actions
that i have presented here they are of
course related translations can be
provided between different accounts
and pearl also in his book has um has
related back to lewis's account
on counterfactuals
viewing these quantum tests as type of
interventions on single systems does
require us to have a better theory of
quantum measurements observations
um i didn't hear sulfur say anything
about the measurement problem but that
should be on the top of the agenda i
think
the pdl logic that i've hinted at here
and presented in part um can be extended
to reasonable entanglement and
multipartite systems
but that does not provide us with a
causal explanation for non-local
correlations that you see in entangled
conferences so there is still a lot to
be done there because
even though you can find analogies
between
standard counterfactuals and quantum
implications
that doesn't really necessarily allow us
to make the step to dangle systems and
definitely not to give a causal
explanation
but i'm very interested to hear also
what other people today will have to say
about that and about quantum cause of
models because i think that might get us
a step closer thank you
okay thanks a lot i have already one
question
hey so so this is a question not about
the quantum part but about the part
earlier around slide 20 that you had um
[Music]
and
yeah really but really the question i'm
trying to get at here is um i'm trying
to think about the way that that that
your
probabilistic model of the counter
factor here relates to that so you
talked about having a possible wells
model and then having subjective
probabilities on each possible world
but
i'm thinking when when i'm explaining
counterfactuals to people i usually i
say you know for example would describe
the type of a patient that's helped or
hurt or always recover and never recover
and i'm very clear that although we use
these words helped hurt boys
uh et cetera that sort of suggests some
modal
operation
that uh but that doesn't exist
essentially that we have a population of
subjects and then uh some of them you
know may may be assigned treatment by
some natural process or some or but we
could also give all of them treatment
but the basic point is there is no
dynamic change that there's just you
know the set of units exist and they get
treatment it could be by an external
process or it could be in an indulgence
process and then there's an outcome
and there isn't a sort of change from
one one
the world doesn't change from one to
another and in a certain sense
what i'm trying to say is it seems as if
in a statistical causal model you have
a population of of possible worlds that
then evolve forwards rather than just
having a single one so so i guess my
question is
can you do yeah can you extend what
you're describing here so we're not
talking about just one system but
populations of systems
with distributions over them
well that's interesting yeah no that's
very interesting question i mean
um so when i later on presented also the
causal interventionist modalities and
the account that halperin has then what
i've
hinted at here is just the most basic
uh modalities but of course even
halperin in his book he has
uh much more complicated
models in the background where
you would have an ordering over possible
walls depending on the type of
interventions that you do and you have a
ranking of the over them
and using that ranking then you can make
much more fine-grained um
[Music]
statements so for him in that case it
would allow you to say well because it
is not a zero one thing but it should be
graded and that relates back to this
probabilistic account so i think the
models can be made much more complicated
in the background having rankings and
orderings over them but
i didn't
yeah so i didn't present that here but i
think that is possible so that should
not be too complicated of course
i mean the more features that you add to
it
the more complicated the setting will
become but i mean in the literature i
think there are examples of where
um
halperin for instance has worked with
these rankings over possible worlds um
in the underlying models so
so i think that should be it should be
possible to generalize that but that
indeed i mean the most basic setting
that i've presented here that is not
present
i have a really really really basic
question um
when you introduced the the
dynamics
you you use the term over and over again
for the you have after the antecedent
blah right and one assumes that dynamics
has to do with changes in time and so on
but then you said you can recover the
material conditional but the material
conditional has no temporal
connotations at all
so
so i i take it do you mean you can
recover the material conditional with an
additional temporal restriction on it
well these models themselves don't have
any i don't know where is my material
conditional i think it's uh
is it simple does after mean literally
temporarily after when you say after
because that's the way it reads
yeah indeed it does i mean so in the way
that dynamic episodic logic and the
dynamic conditionals look at it it does
mean you either go to a next state
where phi is true or you go to a new
model where you have intervened on file
and the the afterwards
i mean
the
the temporal reading so the temporal
modalities are not included in this but
it really means a succession of models
you go from one model to another
succession of states
now for the material implication is
crucial that the state is the same as
where phi is true so
the action itself so the the alpha
action for the material implication is
one in which the state does not change
you only check if phi is true and you
stay at the same state and
psi has to be true at that same state so
that is indeed the only one where there
is no temporal evolution
of any type so i'm staying so the
the the relation there is a loop
relation that gets me back to the same
state s so as has to be true at
state uh phi has to be true state s and
i'm checking in that same state if psi
is true and if that is the case then the
material conditional falls so you're
right there is no
temporal change in that case but then
most of the other ones there is but
the the one in which there is no
temporal
change would be a special case of the
other of the whole set of all kinds of
other actions that you can
that you can model
so there is also a question online but
uh maybe mikhail weisman can ask it
directly
on soon
i can also like
sure um i can unmute myself um
an actual quantum measurement
doesn't really in general lead to a
sharply defined subspace
but
uh
the outcome is typically consistent
with
a bigger set of subspaces but more
consistent with some than the other than
others in other words it's probabilistic
you get a density matrix out
um
is the generalization to that not
sharply defined um
measurement output uh
pretty straightforward um or
do we go back to the previous talk about
adding adding logarithms of
prior density matrices and
[Music]
result
well look as a logician
i think that these density matrices
they're used to capture mixed states
right so my talk here today was only
about pure states now if you look at
what the meaning is of these mixed
states
then actually there is some kind of
epistemic uncertainty over the set of
pure states we just don't know which so
we work with a larger collection because
there is a notion of uncertainty
ingrained in what this mixed state is
now of course in quantum physics it's
very used useful we can work directly
with the density operators in a logical
setting
but would be much more straightforward
to actually make that uncertainty fully
explicit so epistemic logic is a logic
to reason and to model uncertainty
and instead of just plugging in
everywhere where i use a pure state a
mixed state um
my id would be to actually go and make
the epistemic uncertainty explicit and
capture it and
yeah in in a sophisticated way this we
did not do we've worked with density
operators as well
but i mean most of the work that we've
done and and the most part where the
logic is very well behaved is on pure
states
so
but i think it it requires uh
a nice setting to really look further
into the density
thanks
okay so i also have a question so i
propose that you stay online but we are
already over time so maybe we can stop
there
and
we start again i guess at 20 to 11.
thanks a lot
thank you
yes